Okay, so let's now talk about the democratic
party and the Iowa.
A state democratic party.
The timing of this could not be worse, but
the reputation of the democratic party is
in shambles after the absolute fiasco of Monday
nights, Iowa caucus.
Now, there are essentially two sides to this,
and I alluded to this earlier, there are people
who are saying this is nothing other than
a technical snafu.
It's good that it happened early in Iowa in
the first caucus rather than, you know, at
some later point we can now prevent it from
happening again.
I believe it's Nevada that was scheduled to
use the same app or tech system for their
upcoming vote and now they are deciding not
to because of what happened in Iowa.
Okay.
That's one side.
It's a technical snafu and the timing of it
is really bad.
The other side has gone into more conspiratorial
stuff and I don't say that pejoratively, there's
a definition for what a conspiracy would be.
And um, there are, the gist of it is that
it links everything that happened on Monday,
uh, to a DNC.
Uh, Pete budaj edge consultant conspiracy
mostly to deny Bernie Sanders the nomination
that there are variations, there are different
flavors of the conspiracy theory, but that's
roughly the gist of it.
So what's important is very often people fall
for a conspiracy theory merely because the
motive seems to check out absent anything
else.
So let's just break it down piece by piece.
And we shouldn't be afraid to do this.
This is not out of hand dismissing a conspiracy,
but it is also not irrationally feeding it.
The first part is motive.
There is no doubt that the DNC and the establishment
does want to deny Bernie Sanders denomination.
We've been seeing countless examples of how,
uh, this, um, uh, manifests very early on
there were stopped Bernie meetings peed Buddha
judge was part of those meetings.
We are seeing Hillary Clinton, uh, reappear
more and more in the public spotlight very
often to criticize Bernie on the Howard stern
show in that recent docu-series on the recent
podcast whose name escapes me, uh, but I talked
to you about on a Monday.
So there's no question that there is an establishment
effort to try to prevent Bernie Sanders from
being the nominee.
That's not really the focus of the Monday
fiasco.
I tend to arrange hypotheses from simplest
to most complex.
The conspiracy theories about Iowa while possible
seem less likely to me than what we know to
be true, which is unfortunately most people
aren't good at their jobs in competence is
everywhere.
The 80 20 rule tells us about this.
Hanlon's razor tells us not to attribute to
malice what can be appropriately attributed
to incompetence or ignorance.
That still is the most likely scenario to
me, but importantly, and I'm trying to do
this more and more since reading Annie Duke's
book, thinking in bets.
When I say I think it's more likely that this
is incompetence rather than a conspiracy.
I'm not saying that it's 100% right.
What I am saying is that if I had to bet,
I believe it is more likely that this is incompetence
and not a conspiracy.
We should talk more in these terms.
None of us know for sure, but if you said
to me, what would, what would my return have
to be on a dollar bet for me to bet that it's
a conspiracy versus that it is merely incompetence,
I would need a bigger return on the conspiracy
bet in order to make it because I think it
is less likely.
If the Iowa democratic party was going to
rig the results, wouldn't they rig it so that
the person who gets the most delegates would
also get the most number of votes?
Because when we looked at the reports of voting,
as of right now with 71% reporting, this may
have changed by the time that that you guys
watch this clip or listen to today's show.
Bernie Sanders has more raw votes, but P boot
edge edge has more delegates that is creating
way more questions.
It is getting people fired up.
It is getting people saying, this is just
like Trump winning the electoral college,
but losing the popular vote.
Bernie had more votes.
Bernie should have more delegates.
If they were rigging it, they would rig it
so that the total vote count also favors P
boot edge edge.
If that was the point of this entire thing.
Now as far as the DNC being in shambles, Nathan
Robinson wrote a piece in the guardian where
he says it is a technical snafu, but it is
a technical snafu that could not have come
at a worse time and it is a technical snafu
which directly helps some people and directly
hurts some people.
The setup is 2016 where the DNC was widely
slammed for putting their thumb on the scale
for Hillary against Bernie Sanders.
This includes super delegates.
This includes the initial scheduling of debates,
including like on a Sunday night on a three
day weekend, which just hurts any challenger
and reinforces the de facto front runner.
Um, the whole story you likely are familiar
with from 2016.
So since 2016 there has been this question
of, well, what is the DNC going to do this
time?
Are they going to play more fair?
They did the right thing by removing superdelegate
voting from the first round at the DNC.
I don't want to rehash the details of that,
but that makes the process more democratic.
But suspicions were still high going into
2020 and the primary that things were not
going to be totally on the up and up.
And very quickly we started seeing Hillary
Clinton jump in to slam Bernie at a number
of different opportunities.
There are discussions happening in the uh,
uh, the basements and back hallways of the
DNC about, well maybe we push super delegate
voting back to the first round at the DNC
debate qualification rules are being changed
to potentially allow Michael Bloomberg into
the debates, which is again, not something
that is going to help Bernie Sanders.
So in short, tensions are running super high
and this is the exact time that the DNC should
not fail.
And Monday they failed their entire tech system
for the Iowa caucus failed.
There are people saying, well, it's more of
the Iowa democratic party, not the DNC.
This is perceived as all part of the same
apparatus and it looks terrible.
The DNC comes away looking in competent, changing
rules, a failing app, unable to report a report
results at exactly a time when many Americans
are considering, do I stay home?
Do I vote for Trump?
I don't really like Trump, but the DNC seems
like it's in over its head.
And then you read about the DNC failing miserably
and embarrassingly at the first opportunity
to count votes.
The optics are a train wreck.
And by the way, the coin flips for the uneven
delegate counts in Iowa.
I get why it's done this way.
I understand that the meaning of one delegate
in one precinct is tiny, tiny, tiny, but when
you're selecting who's going to run against
Donald Trump, you are just opening yourself
up to criticism and ridicule by using coin
flips to decide about delegates.
Now that this happened, who is going to trust
the DNC to run primaries for the rest of the
election and just as importantly Donald Trump
and the right have been trying to frame the
DNC as exactly this.
Trump and the right have been saying the DNC
is incompetent, the DNC can't run an election.
The DNC is trying to screw Bernie again.
They're unable to get out of their own way
and the DNC hands Trump a gold mine of fodder
and on Monday night, Donald Trump within minutes
of this fiasco was tweeting about it like
we went through on yesterday's show.
It's a comedy of errors and it all is another
little push towards the outcome of a Trump
reelection.
We'll talk about very good poll numbers
for Trump on the bonus show today and also
on tomorrow's program.
But this could not have come at a worse time
for the, uh, for the democratic party, the
David Pakman show